a warning that our crime correspondent
Martin brunt's report includes graphic
descriptions of the alleged violence
right from the start
we were having sex and he put his hands
round my throat and strangled me until I
lost consciousness
and when I came round he was still
having sex with me a young woman who
says she was the victim of sexual
violence and rape her attacker she says
was social media influencer Andrew Tate
with all these chicks just stuck in her
house sitting there bored completely in
love with me tate is facing a claim for
damages from four women in the UK three
who worked in his internet sex business
and Alice not her real name who says he
strangled her how close do you think you
came to being seriously hurt the next
day one of my eyes all the whites of my
eyes had got completely red in one of my
eyes
and I looked it up afterwards and it was
just lack of oxygen to your brain where
your blood vessels start bursting to try
and get more oxygen into your brain that
was quite scary why didn't you go to the
police I was worried that maybe I would
get blamed they would say well you were
having sex with him anyway it's kind of
your own fault
Alice says she met Tate in a bar in
Luton the town where they both lived it
was 10 years ago they had two one-night
stands
she says it was the second in which Tate
turned violent that's why she's planning
to sue him
I just hope that he can be held
accountable for what he's done and
spread the message of Education about
consent and hope that more women might
feel comfortable coming forward with
stories of stuff that's happened to them
not necessarily by him just in general
the lawyer representing all four women
said they wanted to see Tate in court
civil or criminal our clients have
suffered immeasurably and they've
suffered significant loss not just the
the physical harm that that they alleged
occurred but also the fact that they've
been unable to work because of the
trauma they experienced and so they're
perfectly entitled to seek compensation
there's no embarrassment there's no
shame in that if it can help them
rebuild their lives so be it a spokesman
for Andrew Tate said he vehemently
denied the women's claims did not
condone violence of any kind towards
women and had only ever had consensual
sex
he's now under house arrest in Romania
suspected of rape people trafficking and
exploitation his UK accusers he said
we're trying to take advantage of his
current situation
Martin brunt Sky News
here